all right so you're learning the two
beat weave how do you go from having
your POI moving in together time to
having your POI moving in Split time
like this that's the topic of this video
Drex here from drexfactor POI sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today we're going to do a deep dive
on timing inside of two and eventually
three beat weaves and how you can really
really nail that split time instead of
the together time version but before we
dive in I want to give a quick shout out
to the Friends of the channel big thanks
to dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys and Ultra POI for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible you
can learn more about all of these
amazing companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
that I have down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lei
machinski and Becca pekunen thank you so
very much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission so I will confess
that back in the day when I first
started to learn how to spin POI this
was also how I first attempted to do my
weaves and part of that just is that
spinning the POI in together time that
is having the POI both hit the bottom of
their Beats at the same time it just
feels kind of natural you know we're
used to thinking of having both of our
hands do the same thing at the same time
and switching into a split time kind of
feel where we have one POI hitting the
bottom of its beat while the other one
is hitting the top takes a little bit of
time to train but the weaves that come
out of it do have that nice rhythmic
feel to them and that's why they're
considered to be the version of The
Weave that most people like to try and
get to and if the terms together time
and split time are new to you I will
include a link to a video I've done on
timing and Direction down in the
description as well as up in the cards
if you're watching on YouTube so if you
do not have split time down in muscle
memory just yet you're still kind of
struggling to keep the timing on this
and everything that's okay you don't
actually need it in order to figure out
split time inside of a two beat weave or
even a three beat weave there's actually
a little tip that I can give you that
will help you find the timing on this
alright so Step One is you're going to
wrap up those POI so that you are
holding the POI heads in your hands next
we're going to go through a couple
different hand positions the first is
going to be with your POI at your sides
and think of it as your right hand is
going to be sitting right next to the
right side of your rib cage your left
hand is going to be sitting right next
to the left side of your rib cage
they're up close this is what we call
native side right on right left on left
the other position is going to be with
your arms crossed out in front of you
like you're going to try and create an X
yeah one hand is going to be on top of
the other now I am right hand dominant
so I tend to find that my right hand
winds up going on top your mileage may
vary all right so starting with our
hands at our sides here we're going to
basically move them in half circles into
each of these positions yeah so we're
going to go from hands at our sides to
hands cross us but we're going to do it
one hand at a time we're going to start
with the left hand and when we go from
hands at our sides to hands crossed
you're going to have your hand kind of
jump a little bit like it's like it's a
little frog going from one position one
lily pad to another yeah so we're going
to start off it's always going to be the
hand on bottom that moves first so left
hand is going to be the first frog jump
and then the right hand is going to be
the second frog to jump and you should
wind up in a position where you have
that right hand on top and that left
hand on bottom and your hands are kind
of crossed a little bit here yeah next
we're going to go ahead and Trace out
the bottom of the circle so now it's
like you're pulling something back away
from the front of you yeah again we have
the left hand start comes back to its
position right hand goes down and around
back to its side position so it's we
have the left hand hops the right hand
hops the left hand pulls the right hand
pulls so we're going from cross cross
open open again cross cross open open so
I want you to go ahead and give me 10
reps of this just to get into muscle
memory thinking left hops right hops
left pulls right pulls left hops right
hops left pulls right pulls going back
and forth like that 10 times now from
here I want you to let out one coil of
the POI and we're going to try this
again what you're going to do is every
time you hop the POI is basically going
to hop a little higher and it's going to
drag a little lower so again we have
left hop right hop left pulls right
poles left hop right hop left pulls
right pulls keep your POI short because
they're probably going to get a little
wild at some points in here and you want
to make sure that they're not likely to
hit any parts of your body that is going
to have a bad time if they do
left hand right hand left hand right
hand as you go through okay cool now let
the POI out to full length and we'll do
this again
left over right over left under right
under yeah now we're going to add one
element to this and that is that as we
come out of this place where we have our
hands crossed we're going to swing the
POI a little bit more so rather than
just pulling the left hand out we're
actually going to spin it at our side
for a second we're going to let it go
past our right shoulder before we pull
it out let me show you that again so
from stopped right here the left hand
POI we're going to swing it back past
our shoulder and it's when it's pointed
out away from you you're gonna let it
sink down beneath the right hand like so
I'll show you that from the other side
we do get the left hand moving and sweep
it back but you ask the right hand's in
the way how can you avoid tangling them
that's the next part of this okay so
we're going to think that we're going to
count one two in our heads so the left
hand starts the right hand starts and
what happens then is once left hand
right hand and starts the right hand POI
is suddenly no longer in the way for the
left-hand POI as it's coming back out so
what this winds up being is from the
sides we do left hand right hand left
hand right hand and we're able to unwrap
back to each native side just like that
so I want you to go ahead and work on
this thinking Left Right spin left spin
right and then come back to your sides
again Left Right spin left spin right
let me show you that from the other side
we do Left Right spin left spin right
and we come back out all right so I want
you to practice this until it starts to
feel natural just be able to do left
right left right on autopilot like this
yeah
and the next step is that we're going to
try and shorten up the amount of time
that you're sitting there with the POI
waiting yeah so I'm going to think left
right one one thousand two one thousand
three one thousand left right to come
out left right one one thousand two one
thousand three one thousand left right
to come back out I'm then going to go
down to left right one one thousand two
one thousand left right back out left
right one one thousand two one thousand
left right back out and then going to go
down to just one second going left right
one thousand and back out and left right
one thousand left right back out so our
final step of this is that we're going
to try and take out the pause entirely
so we do left right left right and look
at that it's pretty close to being a two
beat weave left right left right so in
Split time we are wrapping our hands and
unwrapping our our hands wrapping our
hands and unwrapping our hands
eventually you should just be able to
get to the point where you can do this
on autopilot and think left right left
right coming in and back out of that
cross position left right left right
left right left right just like that and
of course if you're struggling with
doing the opposite two beat weave that
is you might have left on bottom down
you can use this same technique to learn
how to do it with the right hand on
bottom thinking the right goes first and
we do right left right left right left
right left and then we add the POI in
going right left right left right left
right left and do it with the point full
length right left right left again right
left right left before just trying to go
straight through it right left right
left right left right left
and thus you can break down both the two
beat weave with your dominant hand on
top as well as the two beat weave with
your non-dominant hand on top and of
course this tip is really helpful if you
say are doing the three beat weave and
you're noticing that consistently you're
having a problem with falling into
together time on one side in this case
I'm always losing my timing when I'm on
my left side here when I'm trying to get
my left hand on top the way that you can
Workshop that is quite frankly just do
this drill but do it from the
perspective of trying to just get that
one hand on top with my left hand on top
I have to start with my right so I think
right left right left and work through
the exercise until I get to a point
where it feels much more comfortable
keeping my POI in Split time as my left
hand goes over cool so I hope that that
breakdown was helpful if you got
anything out of this video please make
sure to like comment share and subscribe
to keep the conversation going and to
help people find find this video so
hopefully they can learn from it and
help my channel grow
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
the kind support of all of these nice
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon and they along
with the people listed down in the
description helps to make this video and
all the videos on my channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support and if you are not
currently a supporter and you would like
to become one you can do so by heading
on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up you can get
access to some pretty awesome rewards
there and even better you'll be helping
me out in my mission to bring flow Arts
to The Wider world so go check that out
please and thank you if you dug this
video and you would like to check out
some of my other beginner tutorials you
can do that by checking out the playlist
link that I have down in the description
or up on screen if you are watching on
YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you'll like this top link
right here so maybe check that out as
well thank you so much for watching make
sure to get outside to flow today and
I'll see you with a new video real soon
peace